Fox Ridge Park in Henderson looks like
your average community park there are
children playing people walking their
dogs and everyone just enjoying the
community that they live in but ghost
enthusiasts will tell you that it is a
hot spot for Paranormal Activity these
are the swing sets that they say that
the little boy
that's a Wings on around midnight some
people have witnessed seeing the swing
move by itself late at night and he does
not like being watched the rumor is if
you look him in the eyes he will turn
into a demon and vanish I asked local
Ghost Hunters what they have picked up
in the park and an intuitive tarot
consultant to see if there were any
messages that were being sent from
Beyond what brought us over to the swing
set this was maybe eight years ago
um we were walking around around two in
the morning and the swing started
swinging back and forth really gently
[Music]
um we had a session for about 30 40
minutes with the SLS camera in the
spirit box so what Spirit Box does is it
flips through stations of static a ghost
and Spirits can talk through uh the
white noises they kept telling us to
help and it kept uh he kept telling us
to
um
play with him help him and he said that
he was trapped I'm also going to be
running
this app so what this
leave me alone it just said leave me
alone so what this does except magnetic
energy from that they say Spirits can
manipulate words that come out of here
hey if you want us to leave
says purgatory
traps all together I've experienced I
would say a good five to ten different
Spirits at this park alone
who do you want here
so it did say it said psychic okay mono
we need your expertise here to see if
we're getting any sort of messages from
any of the spirits here okay I need to
be quiet for a second while I
concentrate on that
[Music]
so there's a there's a young a young boy
right here that's coming up in the cards
and that it's it's all it's been in the
last three years that it feels like he
wants to get a story out he wants to get
um a message out but what's really
interesting is smack in the middle of
this reading is a card that indicates he
wants to be set free he doesn't want to
be here anymore it's um and it's
probably part of the reason why he's not
afraid or doesn't deny any publicity
about him because he's looking for a way
to be set free are you I know that your
specialty is focusing on the future and
more people that are here yes in
physical form is my specialty
um in other words I I look at what
happens you know what's going on with
you now what's likely to have moving
forward there are times that when I'm in
a reading with someone there will be an
obvious message that comes from the
other side but I I okay did you just see
that did you you just see that
[Music]
the car flipped over it just flipped
over randomly it so there's a card
called courage that just flipped over he
wants to be put in the spotlight that's
why he's so
um eager or excited that this attention
is here right now but for that to just
flip over like that I always pay
attention when that happened I saw it it
happened too it just randomly flips over
so he's here and I've got goosebumps
like crazy right now
thank you